it has been traditionally a very
important part of wedding calling
everybody that you know how expensive
can a wedding really get weddings are
expensive you know an average wedding I
would say would start at about forty
thousand dollars and they would go all
the way up to I mean anything really
$500,000 $600,000 who can really afford
this kind of cash I think Americans they
save their money for education over here
like the minute your kid is born you're
saving for your kids wedding
what is that sensible or not I'm not
sure but it happens so it's not that you
have cash at that point of time it's
literally your life savings it's your
and your parents life savings that are
put into Indian weddings which is why
people throw such lavish weddings it
seems to me that what you're saying that
the most pivotal or the most momentous
occasion in one's life is a wedding is
getting married then here it is the
divorce rates are still low so again
maybe won't be able to do it again yeah
you know and people say that look India
is like full of so many different
religions and languages and cultures and
there are a few things that really bind
the country together right
they say cricket is one Bollywood is
second and weddings are a third so it's
literally like that one thing which
everybody loves to come together and
celebrate so it's it's really a cultural
thing